jackie chan
declares i want to be a chinese
communist party member this is a variety
story
jackie chan has long been one of hong
kong celebrities who most frequently
prominently engages in propaganda
efforts for the
mainland ruling communist party but he
recently took this public devotion to
the chinese regime to a new level chen
declared his admiration for the party at
a symposium organized by the china film
association last week to study and
implement the spirit of a keynote speech
delivered
by chinese president xi jinping abroad
they often say
proud to be chinese i'm very lucky to be
a chinese person
but i'm also very jealous that you all
are
party members i just think the chinese
communist party
is really so magnificent says jackie
chan
what the party says what it promises it
doesn't need a hundred years to
accomplish
it will definitely accomplish it in just
a few decades
i want to be a party member that
is this like an article from the onion
or is this actually that can you pull
this article
this is variety what's the hollywood
movie star jackie chan what's this
what's the club
[Music]
right so i mean the the chinese
communist party is the most exclusive
club in the world
right if you're a member of the party
everything's taken
for you right so of course he wants to
be a party member you
if you want to live in china and hong
kong and you want to be a part of that
and you're not a part of the chinese
communist party
what are you you're you're on the
outside you're on the outside so in
other words jackie chan wants to be a
maid man
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye